let's think about what will happen if we
have this molecule ELISA name it we have
one two three four five carbons no
double bond so five tells us pent it's
pentane and it has two groups on the
number three carbon one two three
doesn't matter which side we start
counting from we have a bromo group and
we have an ethyl group two carbons right
there so on the three carbon so we have
three bromo three bromo three ethyl
three ethyl pentane right here so we
have three bromo three ethyl pentane
dissolved in a solvent of in a solvent
and this right here it's an alcohol and
it has two carbons right there two
carbons so meth so it is ethanol so this
right there is ethanol so let's think
about what might happen if we have three
bromo three ethyl pentane dissolved in
some ethanol now ethanol already has a
hydrogen it's not super eager to get
another proton although it does have a
partial negative charge it is polar
oxygen is very electronegative so it has
a partial negative charge so maybe it
might be willing to take on another
proton but it doesn't want to do so very
badly so it's actually a weak base so
ethanol right here is a weak base so
it's not strong enough to just go
nabbing hydrogen's off of carbons like
we saw in an e2 reaction so it's just
going to sit passively here and maybe
wait for something to happen now what
might happen well we have this bromo
group right here we have this bromine
and the bromide anion is actually a
pretty good leaving group it's a fairly
large molecule it's able to keep that
charge because it's spread out over a
large electron cloud and it's connected
to a tertiary carbon right this carbon
right here this carbon right here is
connected to one two three carbon so if
it were to lose its electron if it were
to lose that electron right there it
would be might not like to do it but it
would be reasonably stable it's within
the realm of possibilities it could
occur so maybe in this first step since
bromine is a good leaving group and this
carbon can be stable as a carbo cation
maybe and bro the bromine with all is
already more electronegative so it was
already hogging this electron maybe it
takes it all together so let me draw so
neutral bromine has one two three four
five six seven valence electrons
maybe it swipes this electron from the
carbon and now it'll have eight valence
electrons and become bromide so what
happens now and of course the ethanol
did nothing it's a weak base wasn't
strong enough to react with this just
yet so what is happening now so this is
going to be the slow reaction so right
here what I said you know this isn't
going to happen super fast but it could
happen this is actually the rate
determining step rate determining rate
determining not determining determining
this is the rate determining step so
what happens after that so let me just
paste everything again so this is our
set up to begin with but now that this
little reaction occurred what will it
look like
well the bromine has left so let me
clear that out let me clear out the
bromine edit clear and actually took an
electron with it so it's bromide so let
me draw it like this so I'll do it in
blue so this is the bromine so the
bromine is right over here it had one
two three four five six seven valence
electrons it swiped this magenta
electron from the carbon now it has
eight valence electrons it has a
negative charge the carbon lost an
electron so it has a it has a positive
charge and it's you know somewhat stable
because it's a tertiary carbo cation so
now let's think about what's happening
and I want to point out one thing in
this first step of a reaction only one
of the reactants was involved this rate
determining the slow step of reaction
this doesn't occur nothing else will but
now that this does occur everything else
will happen quickly but in our rate
determining step we only had one of the
reactants involved so it's analogous to
the sn1 reaction but we're going to see
here is that we're actually eliminating
and we're going to call this an e1
reaction we're going to see that in a
second actually the elimination has
already occurred the bromide has already
left so hopefully you see why this is
called an e1 reaction
it's elimination efore elimination and
the rate determining step only involves
one of the reactants right here it
didn't involve it didn't involve in this
case the weak base but now that the
broom let's now that the bromide has
left let's think about whether this weak
base this ethanol can actually do
anything it does have a partial negative
charge over here it does have a partial
negative charge and on these ends has
partial partial positive charges so it
is somewhat attracted to hydrogen or to
protons I should say two positive
charges but you know not so much that it
can swipe it off of things that don't
that aren't reasonably acidic now that
this guy is a carbo-cation this entire
molecule actually now becomes pretty
acidic which means it wants to give away
protons or I guess another way you could
view it is it wants to tog it wants to
take electrons depending on what you
want
whether you want to use the
bronsted-lowry definition of acid or the
Lewis definition either way it wants to
give away this well it wants to give
away a proton it could be this one it
could be that one it has excess positive
charge it wants to get rid of its excess
positive charge so it's very it's
reasonably acidic enough so that it can
react with this weak base and what you
have now is the situation what you could
have now is the situation where on this
partial negative charge of this oxygen
let's say let me pick a nice color here
let's say this purple electron right
here
it is it can be donated or it will it
will swipe the hydrogen proton then
hydrogen's electron hydrogen's electron
will be taken by the larger molecule in
fact it'll be attracted to the carbo
cation so it will go to the carbo cation
just like that now in that situation
what occurs well what's our final
product so let me draw it here so this
this part of the reaction is going to
happen fast the rate determining step
happens slow the leaving group had to
leave the carbo cation had to form
that's not going to happen superfast
once that forms it's not that stable and
then this thing will happen this is fast
so let me just paste everything actually
let me just read let me just paste
everything again aid the drawing so now
so
now we already had the bromide it had
left the bromide had left and now the
hydrogen is gone let me clear this the
hydrogen from this carbon from that
carbon right there is gone now this this
electron that electron is still on is
still on this carbon but the electron
that was with this hydrogen is now on
the carb Oh what was the carbo cation so
that electron right here is now over
here and now this bond this bond right
over here is this bond we formed an
alkene and now the what was an ethanol
now a hydrogen proton and now becomes a
positive cation so let me draw that so
this right here this electron this
electron ends up being given so it's no
longer with the ethanol it's no longer
with the ethanol so it's not no longer
with the ethanol it gets given to this
hydrogen it gets given to this hydrogen
right here that hydrogen right there and
now they have formed a new bond and
since it since this oxygen gave away an
electron it now has a positive charge it
now has a positive charge and all along
the bromide anion had left in the
previous step so the bromide anion is
floating around with its eight valence
electrons one two three four five six
seven and then it has this one right
over here that makes it negative and
then our reaction is done we had a weak
base
we had a weak base and a good leaving
group a tertiary carbon and the leaving
group left we only had one of the
reactants involved it was eliminated and
then once it was eliminated then the
weak base was able to take was then able
to take a hydrogen off of this molecule
and that allowed this molecule to become
an alkene formed a double bond this is
called an E and I already told you this
is an e1 reaction efore elimination in
this case of the halide one because the
rate determining step only in
involved one of the molecules it did not
involve the weak base we'll talk more
about this and especially different
circumstances where you might have well
one the different types of you one
reactions you could you could see what
you know which hydrogen is going to be
picked off and all of the things like
that and we're going to see when II 1 e2
sn1 or sn2 what what's kind of the
environment or the reactants that need
to be there for each one of those to
occur in different circumstances